bella domanda è perché io bevo dalla
bottiglia dell'olio e le bottiglie sì
non lo sapevi lubrico i neuroni ma se
vuoi lubrificanti e in orari c'è
un'altra pugliese se non posso
verificare se anche va bè metti a va
bene ciao ragazzi siamo io e giampiero
sentimenti su visto che vi è piaciuto
talmente ma sei andato veramente bene vi
dovevamo fatti si andrà bene perché
l'africa altro oltre le views dato un
sacco bene i feedback cioè attiri un
sacco di persone forse all'interno
tenuti che io non porto la barba la
barba poi capelli normali normali e poi
le sopracciglia principale a un
superpotere che è sempre adorato che
questo oggi giocheremo a tod's sushi che
un gioco che si gioca in due
non so cosa bisogna fare però si gioca
in due ed è un collettivo a io sono che
sono il blu quindi io sono grandicello
siamo contro uno contro l'altro se
magari il gioco ci spiegasse cosa
dobbiamo fare
grati ai piatto con quelle cose fasi e
questo li eccolo no
maledetto sporco
ecco noi però non va dove sono quello a
destra hanno capito adesso tu sei quello
blu e non ho capito questo difficile
spiega nona prova con spero che questo
video vi sia piaciuto è stato bellissimo
la campionaria l'ho scoperto io e tutto
esatto non tanto il proprio nel sushi e
del cervello è bellissimo magari ho
capito come funziona dai dai 230
migranti salmone e gamberetti porca
vacca il bello però hanno tutto sulla
tua parte allora però io gioco a sei
anni si è cagato e questo certo invio
per forza giusta skill dai brani così la
travel e difficilissimo blasio rifatti
dei cani anche se infatti ci siamo noi
si è mai visto ma non hai visto mai
vista a sai perchè perchè quando clicchi
1 e sbagli poi non puoi cliccare per un
po come non è questo
eccola eccolo questa difficilissima sei
giornate le 34 un bel casino
ok va bene anche se le date da 2 a 0 a
36 dei due dove tenzione
2 torneo noi ti fa arrabbiare questa
cosa ok singolo xxiii che era un altro
reagì vanta il terzo da il terzo vinto
tutto comunque è un gioco carino mi
piace per le persone intelligenti
forse per te no alla rai perché è
veramente il giro è sì ci sono se fai
questa mini superato direttamente da 20
riuscirà non citarla come mi muovo è di
nuovo nota è quella prima dei fatti ma
rimango di qua edizione mammamia
difficili siete veramente un casino è
veramente difficile
ecco lo devo a recuperarla minchia no no
dobbiamo fare questa è quella giusta che
tipo chi segna vince la forma veramente
te lo devi prendere basta può essere
difficilissima per me è perfetto per
tema davvero difficile ciao ragazzi non
c'e la voglia di sushi incredibile
sì infatti sto veramente ore 21 amico
mio
sto veramente morendo di fame signor
cara al calato tra l'altro ha d'altro
lato
oddio questo difficilissimo ok
che paura no dai a torino la veramente
distrutto tutti ancora una che dobbiamo
fare no no vabbè dai giampiero e il
toschi master si sushi ma mi è piaciuto
anche me è stato molto carino grazie
tod's uscì ha pagato 99 centesimi
all'ora quanti soldi vuoi dare per
scaricarlo ma perché lo devi riscaricare
se c'è scritto no perché gratis però poi
donare a vento 100.000 centomila emilio
milione di euro milioni ad arrivare gia
suicidio ci sono ci sono un milione di
euro l'abbiamo pagato io sia carino
facciamo 50 52 oggi offro io domani
offre un caffè
va benissimo bene a prendi un po di
dimestichezza dei comandi mentre
toccarla io sono a sinistra ok ok ci
sono gli faccia capire che poiché va
bene però viva l'attenzione guarda
guarda arriva mamma donna no l'altro
campo cambiato tutto ok arriva un altro
capiva bene bravo cyrus
una sera perché ora
veramente un gioco figo mai sì sì rai
niente paura quanto vigo da una migliore
ma è bello perché abbiamo due joystick
15 ma competitiva del solito
ok è difficilissimo portava d'altra
parte veramente difficile diciamo di no
ma ci sono sì sì ci siamo e ci siamo ora
uno si va a spetta parlavate combattuto
le astuzie stato bravissimo diavolo
mamma mia che pazzini sia citando mai
essere attenti alle gambe
no è difficilissimo se già scatenati
lines con ayala tra ecco lo aspetta
aspetta aspetta stai tranquilla e mi sa
che cambia come fanno essere così lunghi
del gf non ci hanno dato collo si
infatti è ok
vai no no no ragazzi veramente difficile
sia malissimo e conduceva 3 3 a 5
pensavo che combattuta un'ora che sia
infettivo nave va bene va bene così dai
cioè competitività nell'aria ragazzi no
quando cambiano sono i match point è in
onda non va bene sento l'adrenalina è
difficilissimo si sente si sente dai
detective frate giusta difficile ce la
fai a tre è stato bellissimo il gira
fluence rivincita adesso è bellissimo
giocato veramente divertiti molto bello
mi credevo perfetto pagato 20 euro di
giochi quando molto b schifo io che ho
vinto il cappello
no però come si salva alla grande
come hai fatto a salvarla da lei sbaglia
sbaglia sbaglia qualcosa o hunan lion
guarda competition sì sì infatti molto
dura lo sei fortissimo ma è un dato
incredibile western o ci sia una tattica
qualche il rocket leasys del genere c'è
stato un momento incredibile ma che
cos'ha sbagliato a cliccare ho fatto io
no no no no non vale per niente ragazzi
non vale a regime lo frena veramente
bassa
no no no sei fortissimo del successo
come cosa è successo e anche primari
cortese dai basta ma sbaglia no no no no
ragazzi me lo merito io non esistere
fortissimo del successo a sbaglia no no
come diventare si pensavano buttati sul
cavo questo è operata da re lei no no
sai dellai sbaglia ci sta ma come faccio
ad andare vi faccio vedere un po i no
sono scemo non hanno preso no non è
presa no non è vero per niente da
ragazzi è stato bellissimo ci siamo
creati addosso perché comunque volevo
dire una roba non prendete sti video
come se fossero
documentari perché non funziona così la
giraffa non fa queste cose però è un
gioco molto carino non prendete questi
video come se fossero del messia cielo
sono però non va beh avete i ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto ringrazio
giampiero brave partecipato il video è
come al solito ci vediamo alla prossima
giraffa ora un prossimo video iscritto
nel canale e posate anche la pagina sta
che non di giampiero che la shin
description e se trovassi il telecomando
mi fai l'onore grazie gianpi era ci
vediamo al prossimo video beh ragazzi
[Musica]